carisse on était avec booba on voulait
t'embrasser et du coup bah tu peux lui
dire ou laisser un message
roméo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
perché
[Applaudissements]
certes c'est un peu trop c'est trop
et bien comme ça je suis très content de
te voir je voulais dire un truc si
franchement t'as un amour de mecs parce
que c'est lui qui m'avait dit quand je
viens à paris
je vais venir te voir j ai rien dit il
m'a appelé il m'a laissé un message ce
week-end il m'a dit je viens c'est la
semaine dernière il m'a dit je viens je
veux venir en touche pas à mon poste est
en tout cas déjà je voudrais dire tu es
un homme de parole on va on va quand
même après charisme et juste avant booba
toi tu es prêt soit tu dis ok surtout
sur ce contrat non c'est un contrat de
base
ouais je peux pas être ok surtout tant
que lui l'a pas accepté alors consignes
après on se met d'accord sur le sur la
date exacte etc
mais moi je suis prêt à le signer alors
j'appelle j'appelle j'appelle caris je
vais voir s'il va me répondre que tu
penses tu mens ce qui va me répondre ou
pas non merci
toujours de bon conseil bah ouais bah tu
sais quoi il parlait de la grand-mère à
caressant brouilly fenner dans l'auto
alors j'ai pas numéro de carrie cela en
fait donc voilà je vois la cua booba tu
là oui oui non barrette
non je parle en deuil adacore est donc
tu l'as tu l'as pas du tout et
l'appréhender m
ouais je c'est vrai booba moi je pense
un truc je pense que ce combat ne se
fera jamais moi je pense aussi qu'il
signera pas un c'est sûr donc non il
aurait déjà on aurait trouvé un
compromis
voilà tu penses que je pense aussi que
ça se fera jamais donc j'ai peu d'espoir
messieurs donc vous vous êtes prêts
parce que car il va dire oui mais
pourquoi tu le fais pas en tunisie où tu
vas dire pourquoi tu le fais pas en
suisse non mais tunisie ça aucun sens et
aux réponses et à la tunisie
je sais que c'est mon pays on s'en fout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai un réseau que c'est contre
moi tu va combattre al age and numbers
malaisie a laissé alors attendez je
l'appelle te tutoie comble oui oui
l'appel de là je l'appelle te tue je
l'appelle tout de suite c'est bon c'est
parti on va voir et ça sera les directs
sur michel caris on était avec booba
voilà où il avait une proposition de
faire d'un combat en suisse voilà avec
un combat avec baron vos maltin etc
voilà donc on voulait t'embrasser et du
coup booba tu peux lui dire ou laisser
un message
roméo ça a été avec nous tu étais
content de nous vend très beau temps
[Musique]